going back to drifting i i'm i'm curious
because
uh obviously normal youtubers they have
this kind of
i buy the camera i buy the [ __ ] that's
it i probably have to spend much more
money unless you're mr beast of course
yeah but i mean is it is it hard running
a youtube channel where it
requires you to buy a bunch of [ __ ]
cars and
tires all the time how much a year do
you spend on tires alone ah
it can depend on the year but i mean one
depending on the car
like one one tire can go between
say or four like forty dollars or
forty to a hundred and twenty dollars
per tire depending on how good it is so
let's just let's say like seven or
eighty dollars a tire
so that's two yeah and a regular track
they're probably gonna go through
four if not more depending on how crazy
i see you upload sometimes sometimes
weekly but it was more like
kind of over sporadically over a month
right like yeah and is that every single
time you're making a video you're
probably doing that
no well okay so you i could these days i
think i could
yeah right for various reasons because
the uh the the market
for people to watch those sort of videos
is much bigger that's huge
like every everyone watches youtube now
like everyone yeah it's a thing that's
the only place you can get that sort of
content too like you can't really
get it on tv because it's not on tv or
anything like that so
right now is a really good there's a
good lane for automotive content right
now
uh but the most cost effective content
is
going to uh a meeting or some sort of
cool event
like a festival
you just drive there walk around going
hey guys look at this cool stuff and
the best thing about that is like if i
know what i'm talking about
people which way i'm providing you know
that's kind of like your
it's a video yes again that's another
thing that may be confidential you want
to
explain what that whole thing is oh okay
what's anita show
so most a lot of the audience is gonna
will know what these are
but so itasha is those uh the anime
waifu cars
yeah that are like you know wrapped with
like some character or some theme or
whatever
the ones that always get upvoted on your
reddit or pop up in your feed every once
in a while
right yeah you see them like it'll be
like wow i've never seen any of these
before
yeah you come to japan and this is
entire festivals for it oh yeah
so what itasha means is so in japan when
they refer to a car
like uh an american car you can say it's
an amish
american uh italian car like ferrari or
whatever
yeah but they changed the character for
like italic
the katakana to the kanji for pain
because i mean as i explained the video
when you you look at it a normal person
looks at and goes
[Laughter]
so basically it's literally more like
cringe it's a crazy
crash car yeah is the most accurate way
of putting it
uh but the people who drive those sorts
of things they just don't care they're
like super hard correct yeah this is my
waifu and i love her
and there's there's not much bigger of a
flex than like how to represent your
waifu
slab it all over your car and drive
around in all right that's like the next
stage from just wearing like a t-shirt
with your fastest splice
glasses on right yeah exactly yeah yeah
absolutely it's uh
yeah well yeah it's the step up it's the
t-shirt then it's like the what do you
call the the armor like the badges where
they have all the full
oh yeah yeah right and then it's like up
from you know you have this then it's a
plushie and then it's a figurine and
then it's a car
a car and a lot of the cars do have you
know they put the like the nestle
betty's in there and stuff like that on
the dashboard
yeah yeah yeah so um so some of the most
popular content i've done
on twitch and also on youtube was this
itasha show
yeah that they run every year in tokyo
uh down in odaiba
uh they didn't run it this year
unfortunately yeah obviously
everything's cancelled this year yeah it
was cancelled unfortunately yeah but uh
so
what so when i made that video this was
before i
knew there was such a big crossover in
audience between anime and cars between
cars like it's sort of like the japan
anime
cars there's a big there's actually a
big crossover in the middle there right
uh so and even people are like maybe not
necessarily
into cars like like people who watch
initial d they'll enjoy it because it's
a cool story and it's action whatever
yeah you know so there's all this sort
of stuff too so i went to the show i
thought okay how am i gonna
cover this show i don't want to be like
full on weeb
hey guys look at this look at this you
know look at this big city anime girl
34th edition anime girl from that one
manga panel that you all know
i know like i didn't want to come across
two i wanted to do you want to alienate
my car audience yeah i still wanted to
you can say it you didn't want to come
off as much no i don't want to like i
want to hide my power level
[Laughter]
level one weeb yeah so
i walked around the show talking about i
know i know about the car and this is
the character like i explained like okay
this is like this show
uh it's about this sort of thing
whatever yeah this is ma madoka this
show is yeah
it's a bunch of you know magical girls
and they all die horribly it's really
good well so i've heard i i don't know
i've watched myself i've just heard
things
jokes too like oh you know i wonder what
these guys girlfriends think if they go
pick them up from the train station
these cars
oh wait who am i kidding ha ha ha like
uh sort of like trying to meanwhile yeah
you're like god i wish that was me
you're 100 right
and some people actually took big
offense to like oh man show some more
respect toward these stinks man it's
like
don't you under like you should be able
to understand i'm actually it's
clearly an inside joke right yeah so
anyway so that that got really popular
and all of a sudden i realized
oh i've got this audience and then you
know next time that show ran
i did a live stream on twitch right and
it's probably one of the best maybe not
the biggest
numbers i've ever done but probably the
most engagement i've ever done
right i blew out my data for that down
but no we're going to keep going
i covered this whole show it was really
good i actually talked to
um tv there was a tv uh crew there
and you know they i was they talked to
me and i didn't actually make it on the
show i think because they asked like
so you know what people overseas think
of these cars and japanese tv wants the
you know the nice response oh yes
they're very wonderful
yeah i basically sort of said like
because i was on the live stream and i
didn't want my audience to think i was
trying to be fake or something
yeah a lot of them say like there's a
lot of like really young girls on the
cars and they think that's kind of weird
i mean what do you want to say there's
like you know cameraman
yeah all that tv is hyper positive yeah
yeah yeah yeah so i don't say bad things
i didn't really care
especially japanese too i was meaning
for my for the for the
twitch it was a pog moment it's all
right
dude it's a different beast when there's
a twitch chat on you because it turns
you into like the meme
yeah yeah because you don't want it you
don't want twitter
the crunchyroll anime awards i didn't
want to be cringed so i was like [ __ ]
twitch tracks watching me what would
twitch what would twitch chat respond to
just troll just say dumb [ __ ] yeah so
they can go like pog no way
yeah because i remember i because that
itasha video of yours i think was from
like 2017 or something it was a
long time ago it's like two or three
years at least and i i
like when i heard that you were gonna
come onto the show i was like okay i
gotta you know obviously do some
research yeah on the guest
and i found that itasha video i'm like
why does this video look so
familiar and i remember i watched that
video i think like
maybe like two or three days after it
came out because i i don't know if you
remember but like that video initially
was
getting recommended yeah everything
because i watched that video as well
back then oh really yeah yeah
it was it was what you're trying to say
is algorithm he knew you before you
i knew you were before you would be yeah
but it was cool as well because like i
obviously
very like knew very quickly that like as
you were kind of
explaining the different shows and
whatnot i could very clearly be like oh
yeah this guy knows this [ __ ]
but he clearly just doesn't want to like
show it all he's like
like i've been a closet wii before i
recognize my fellow brethren
you know what i mean